le port du voile dans les bureaux de
vote le débat déchaîné les passions hier
soir dans l'hémicycle pendant près de
deux heures les députés ont bataillé
autour d'un bref amendement finalement
rejetée et maintenant du modem et qui
aurait est interdit tout signe
ostentatoire d'appartenance religieuse
pour le personnel des bureaux de vote
si l'obligation neutralité religieuse ne
concerne que les présidents et
présidentes de bureau le sujet reste
malgré tout très clivant alors les
assesseurs voilée pour ou contre menace
pour la laïcité ou victoire de
l'intégration c'est l'objet de notre
face à face ce soir et pour en débattre
nous sommes avec david guiraud
porte-parole jeunesse la france
insoumise julien houle conseiller
régional est reine en bourgogne franche
comté membre du bureau national du rnd
bon soir tous les deux messieurs merci
d'être avec nous donc c'est une
polémique qui a enflé sur les réseaux
sociaux et qui a fait rage en toutes les
nuits à l'assemblée nationale même si
l'amendement était rejeté un finalement
le précise le débat on le voit reste
extrêmement vif et et surtout très
clivant tout est parti à d'ailleurs de
cette photo publiée par jordan bardella
un duel le dimanche 20 juin lors du
premier tour des régionales voilà cette
photo à voter a dit sobrement un jordan
bardella julian odoul clairement ça nous
a choqués cette photo ce qui porte à
cette question est ce qu'un assesseur
peut arborer un signe ostensible de
religion selon vous oui cette photo est
choquant dans un bureau de vote
la neutralité devrait être la règle la
neutralité devrait être la norme
la neutralité politique et la neutralité
religieuse
cette assesseurs donc qui portent ce
voile islamique qui n'est pas un
vêtement anodin qui évidemment un signe
un emblème politico religieux
contrevient au principe de neutralité et
ce qui est choquant c'est que tous les
six mois
nous avons ce débat sur le voile tous
les six mois
nous avons des provocations les
provocations communautariste islamistes
et tous les 6 mois vous avez le goût
un moment qui est la tête dans le sable
vous avez des débats qui ne sont pas
tranchés parce que clairement il faut
qu'en france on est ce débat en france
le voile n'est pas souhaitable
le voile n'a rien à faire en france le
voile n'est pas la culture française
n'est pas notre identité nationale
le voile n'est pas donc principes
républicains dont clairement il faut
trancher cela que ce soit pour
évidemment les assesseurs que ce soit
d'un qu'en france on est encore ce débat
là pour du personnel qui effectue une
mission de service public et je dirais
la mission de service public la plus
essentielle puisque c'est la leçon de
service public qui favorise qui organise
la démocratie la démocratie doit être
dans ce cadre-là extrêmement rigoureuse
extrêmement neutre on ne pourrait pas
accepter que dans un bureau de vote vous
ayez des logos des pin's des t-shirts de
partis politiques
évidemment que cela contrevient au
principe de neutralité vous ne pouvez
pas accepter que les voiles islamiques
soient exhibé dans un bureau de vote
pareil pour les sorties scolaires les
accompagnatrices colère qui sont dans un
cadre de l'éducation nationale dans la
prolongation de l'éducation nationale
qui effectue une mission de service
public ne devrait pas pouvoir exhiber de
cils politico religieux ostentatoires il
faut qu'une bonne fois pour toutes nos
gouvernants les grandes personnes qui
nous gouvernent tranche ce débat et
arrête de reculer parce qu'à chaque fois
que nous avons ce genre de provocation
c'est la république qui recule ce sont
nos principes qui reculent ça sert à
rien de parler de séparatisme matin midi
et soir
si on n'est pas capable de trancher ce
débat est tout simplement de cantonner
la religion de cantonner l'entrisme de
continuer le prosélytisme en dehors des
affaires de la république en dehors des
bureaux de vote
en dehors des sorties scolaires en
dehors aussi de l'espace public car
encore une fois le voile n'est pas un
vêtement anodin c'est un emblème
politique qui participe du développement
du communautarisme islamique et qui a
entretenu comme tel et on le voit aussi
d'ailleurs à la piscine on le voit sur
nos plages avec ce débat incessant sur
le burqini qui n'est rien qui n'est en
rien un vêtement
religieux d'ailleurs puisque puisque
puisque c'est on le sait très bien
abandonné bien évidemment génère donc
terminé le dur le burqini n'est pas un
vêtement religieux le but le but he qui
est juste un emblème politique qui sert
de provocation permanente pour
développer le communautarisme
il faut que ce débat soit tranché une
bonne fois pour toutes des villes hierro
plusieurs idées qu'on va évidemment dont
on va débattre ici le principe de
neutralité mais aussi c'est vrai cette
incapacité à trancher
manifestement en france sur ce type de
dossier on sent une fébrilité
vous aussi vous pensez qu'il faut très
clairement tranché et dans quel sens
moi je crois surtout que c'est l'été et
que comme chaque été faux pieds des gens
en compet déperdition qui connaissent
rien aux lois de notre pays rien à
l'identité républicaine de notre pays
comme julien odoul qui sortent pour
cracher sur les musulmans pour exister
politiquement je viens au double c'est
un grand champion
on le connaît il l'a déjà fait au
conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté qu'il espérait gagner d'ailleurs
il s'est fait piétiner par le parti
socialiste
là il continue à cracher pour exister
politiquement mais franchement cette
dame elle s'élevait à 1 dimanche
elle s'élevait à 1 dimanche à une
élection il ya que 30% des français qui
sont allés voter pour tenir un bureau de
vote on n'arrête pas de nous parler
d'intégrer les musulmans à la république
et quand vous avez une femme qui va
justement aider à la bonne tenue des
élections
on lui dit qu'il faut qu'elle parte
enfin je veux dire il ya un moment faut
savoir ce qu'on veut
monsieur odoul nous sort des arguments
extrêmement fallacieux il nous dit les
bureaux de vote qui doit y avoir une
neutralité politique et religieuse mais
vous savez pas le droit dans le droit
français la neutralité politique allait
garantir la neutralité religieuse par
contre pour les assesseurs
elle est ouvert pourquoi parce que les
assesseurs et représente pas l'état
monsieur au double ils représentent les
candidats et les candidats ils n'ont pas
à être neutres religieusement vous en
faites ce que vous voulez au sein de
votre organisation politique mais ils
n'ont pas à être neutres religieusement
sinon ça veut dire que vous êtes pour la
dissolution du parti chrétien démocrate
qui n'est pas neutre religieusement
sinon avec des gens comme vous qui
piétine et l'histoire et l'identité de
notre pays n'y aurait pas eu d' abbey
pierre qui est élu député il y aurait
pas eu de chanoine félix kir qui a été
député pendant 22 ans qui a été maire de
dijon de 1945 c'était un résistant
jusqu'à sa mort il y aurait pas eu ça
nous voilà donc en fait qu'on est en
face de gens qui arrivent comme
qui vous donnent des grandes leçons de
république mais qui n'ont pas compris
que la laïcité c'est fait pour apaiser
la france c'est pas fait pour faire des
guerres de religion
et quand j'entends dire que soit disant
il faudrait que les religions ne se mêle
pas des affaires de la france mais enfin
monsieur doute mais vous êtes qui pour
pour dire ça les religions il ya une loi
de séparation des églises et de l'état
qui est clair il n'y a pas besoin de
légiférer
il n'y a pas besoin de passer deux
heures à l'assemblée pour se demander si
une assesseurs doit porter le voile ou
pas pour savoir que la loi de 1905 elle
existe mais pour ça c'est vrai hein faut
connaître le droit
alors bon il faut travailler ces sujets
on va en ce moment messieurs à la racine
à l'assemblée nationale avec la position
de nos 1000 yens député modem dans les
yvelines qui a tenté
donc effectivement de convaincre de
voter cet amendement écouter le fait
d'aller voter c'est quelque chose que
l'on doit sacraliser les lecteurs qui va
voter effectivement ne sait pas qui sont
les assesseurs qui est le président du
bureau et je pense que ce lieu-là doit
être totalement neutre et les assesseurs
doivent être d'une neutralité totale
qu'elle soit politique ou religieuse
comme ça il n'y aura aucune influence
sur le vote
vous êtes donc on fait n'est pas coutume
je viens aux boules totalement d'accord
avec le modem
totalement d'accord avec les propos de
bruno myle yens évidemment et c'est vrai
que brûler les arguments du représentant
de la france islamiste ne m'étonne pas
sont toujours les mêmes c'est à dire on
n'a pas ces deux accompagnatrices
scolaire donc il faut évidemment ouvrir
les bras à celles qui sont voilées on
n'a pas assez d'assesseurs en france
donc on ne peut pas rejeter celles qui
sont voilées et qui contreviennent
excusez moi monsieur guiraud nonobstant
le droit qui contreviennent aux
principes de neutralité puisque vous
oublié quelque chose
la fameuse loi 1905 dont vous parlez
matin midi et soir
vous avez oublié que dans les débats
elles demandaient notamment que les
religions choix discrète discrète dans
l'espace public vous comprenez discrète
et le voile contrevient totalement bafut
ce principe de discrétion bambins tout
ce principe de discrétion parce que je
sais bien que c'est votre nouvelle
clientèle électorale qui est de plus en
plus faibles il faut bien le dire 10
rebonds sous la halle
je les requérants tenue du dab et par
l'assemblée nationale s'est dit ce
monsieur mais monsieur guiraud monsieur
guiraud le chat le voile et le vétéran
soutane c'est discret je sais que pour
vous le voile finalement n'est qu un
serre tête ou qu un bandana
mais la réalité est dramatique
aujourd'hui c'est que le sait que le
voile islamique aujourd'hui est tout
sauf un vêtement et c'est tout sauf la
liberté de le porter le voile islamique
est entretenu et instrumentalisé comme
un emblème du communautarisme et de
l'islamisme à temps des essais libres et
je vais je vais je vais juste je suis
terminé juste amener et que une personne
qui se dévoue comme vous l'avez dit très
justement pour aller dans un bureau de
vote pour effectuer cette mission
essentielle d'organiser un scrutin est
d'aider à sa bonne organisation que
cette personne vienne avec un voile
islamique mais pourquoi le temps le
temps de cette journée ne peut-elle pas
rester neutre neutre voilà pour que la
journée se déroule sereinement compte
tenu de l'importance de la journée
non répond dans quelques instants julien
au 12 mai on va faire un petit détour
par eric ciotti qui en substance dit
exprime cette idée que vient de dire
donc julien on voulait couler si on
débat c'est parce qu'il ya eu des
français assassiné c'est parce qu'il ya
eu un professeur décapité et parce qu'il
y a un problème qu'il convient de
combattre avec énergie et avec
détermination
vous ne voulez rien changé ce texte est
un filet d'eau tiède au moins d'accord
avec lui ou pas qui a le mérite
d'exprimer en tout cas ce qui peut
choquer une certaine partie des français
un symbole politique est ce que vous
comprenez que ça puisse heurter ses
sensibilités la honte au cas mais
j'adore les gens comme monsieur ciotti
ou monsieur odoul qui nous explique que
le voile c'est pas un abîme et c'est
quoi alors si c'est pas un habit pardon
c'est une chaussure c'est quoi ces
essais un cintre c est ca c'est un
lampadaire qui êtes vous pour définir ce
qu'est un habit pardon mais il ya un
moment ça devient ridicule cette
discussion ridicule je vous assure un
parce que ça devient complètement
absurde on débat
deux choses dont on ne sait même plus de
quoi on parle monsieur odoul être en
train de nous dire en gros le voile
islamique nécessite quoi une législation
spécifique c'est ça il faut l'interdire
spécifiquement je vais juste vous
rappeler au cas où vous n'êtes pas au
courant parce qu'en plus il opine du
chef passait bien il connaît pas
l'article premier de la constitution du
4 octobre 1958 à l'article 1er c'est à
dire pas c'est même pas le cinquième de
simenon le premier le plus important je
vais vous lire comme ça vous comprendrez
la france est une république indivisible
laïque démocratique et sociale
et je vous lis je cite elle assure
l'égalité devant la loi de tous les
citoyens sans distinction d'origine de
race ou de religion
donc vous pouvez pas légiférer sur une
religion en particulier c'est
anticonstitutionnel
il faut connaître l'histoire de son pays
il faut connaître la constitution de son
pays et les lois de son pays c'est très
important quand on aspire à gouverner le
pays monsieur 12-0 monsieur guiraud nous
ne faisons aucune distinction entre les
religions et entre les croyants parce
que vous voyez vous parlez de musulmans
moi je parle de français de confession
musulmane parce que moi ils doivent
d'abord être français est français c'est
quoi c'est déjà se plier aux lois de la
république dise et est aussi est aussi à
la culture française aux moeurs
françaises à l'identité nationale parce
que le français mais monsieur monsieur
départ moi la culture veut c'est
monsieur c'est pas marqué d'essai
vous n'êtes pas la culture française et
vos bêtises quand vous parle comme
résister avec les pires imams radicaux
monsieur giraud quand vous manifestez
main dans la main avec le ccf
quand vous manifester avec un boa nahd
en novembre 2019 a donc on a fait une
prestation une femme qu'on peut pas
réussir l'accord de la sudation cas
terroriste choses autrement et et
imaginer tout simplement que ça va
donner moi messieurs ce qu on vous
entend pas seul on parlait tous les deux
en même temps est-ce qu'on ne peut pas
voir justement cet acte comme un être
plutôt apaisant
et d'intégration voilà cette femme qui
est bénévole au service de l'état ce que
ça cette pensée peut vous effleurez
évidemment et surtout et surtout ça
nécessite pas qu'on y passe
j'ai peut-être didier mascella des
revues qui parle de vue qu'il est très
bon
non mais je dis je je dis ça parce que
je dis ça parce que les arguments qui
sont énoncées par monsieur doute sur
l'identité française où la culture
française mais pardon mais ce n'est pas
le rassemblement national qui peut
définir ce qu'est la culture française
ce que j'essaie de vous dire que la vie
justement cet organisateur ans histoire
de monsieur odoul rompe avec le principe
de laïcité
ils veulent une laïcité et d'ailleurs il
ya eu des débats à l'époque ses 20 ans
il y avait des débats l'époque de la loi
de laïcité
vous aviez des gens comme aristide
briand qui vous disaient écouter on a
déjà bien mis l'église catholique à bas
on a fait la séparation des églises et
de l'état
on va peut-être pas interdire la soutane
dans la rue d'accord c'était ce débat là
avant et maintenant c'est la conception
qu'il en parle vous en aviez d'au delà
des référés qui a montré qu'il fallait
au dos de ce qui arrive tous les signes
religieux
effectivement un signe d'intégration
pour soi pas julien odoul cette femme
après tout est bénévole au service de
l'état d'ailleurs votre collègue
bardella pas vraiment l'air effrayé
non mais c'est l'échec total de
l'intégration l'échec total de
l'assimilation car si cette femme était
assimilé aux lois de la république à
notre culture à notre identité nationale
jamais elle ne mettrait cet emblème
politico religieux pour venir effectuer
cette mission de service public
c'est un échec total et le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que vous avez un
gouvernement qui recule en permanence
vous avez d'un côté monsieur blanc caire
qui a deux ans nous disait que le voile
n'était pas souhaitable dans la société
française et la sueur quand même un
symbole extrêmement fort nous sommes
dans un bureau de vote
nous ne sommes pas dans une boulangerie
nous sommes dans un bureau de vote c'est
à dire que c'est là où s'exerce la
démocratie dans notre pays
sixième puissance démocratique du monde
donc clairement est ce qu'à un moment
donné on peut avoir un gouvernement qui
ne tremble pas qu'ils réaffirment nos
principes et qui nous disent tout
simplement le voile comme tous les
signes religieux ostentatoires ne sont
pas souhaitables dans ce cadre là le
voile comme emblème politico religieux
ou être combattue
car encore une fois derrière il ya une
idéologie mortifère en honnête compris
vos deux points de vue merci david lire
merci à julien aux boules d'avoir été
avec nommé david girona qu on voit là on
vous a laissé débattra à temps égal je
pense
merci à tous les deux rapidement mais
vous avez continué david guiraud je vous
connais la loi ne dit pas ce qui est
souhaité par la banque mondiale ce qui
est autorisé ou bien interdits
si vous commencez à dire que la loi
disent qu'ils se tapent site vous
connaissez pas ce que c'est qu'une loi
dans un pays merci à tous les deux voilà
vous avez une mot de la fin merci david
guiraud et julien au double dans
quelques-uns